is the cancellation of Prodigy just the
beginning of a much bigger problem for
both Star Trek and Paramount
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
movie channel
[Music]
now I've spoken to you guys about this a
couple of times but there are problems
at Paramount they owe a crapload of
money now it's not quite worn a
discovery debt that's 50 billion but
they do owe about 20 billion dollars
there have been a couple of business
analysts and now this isn't a business
Channel but we'll get through this as
quickly as we can that are actually
arguing for business reasons that
Paramount is in real trouble and that
this whole streaming experiment is
costing a bloody Fortune a fortune that
they just cannot sustain so Paramount
plus is an entity that is currently in
27 different countries around the world
may have to go if the company as a whole
is going to survive they're even arguing
that within two years Paramount itself
is going to have to be broken up and
sold off into different bits because of
the problems that it's having
now we all know there are too many
streaming services and even though
they've all got brilliant content most
of them they're just too expensive most
people maybe have two whereas 12 months
24 months ago we were having maybe four
or five it's just too expensive and
considering the cost of living crisis it
cannot continue now all the stream of
services except apple apple or cash Rich
they haven't got a problem but all of
the other streaming services and even
Disney are having to cut back now Disney
recently announced that it was removing
a load of content from its service so
that Disney plus was going to have a lot
less stuff on it why did they do that
because having stuff on the service
servers they don't own basically
requires rental they have to pay for it
and by removing as much as stuff as they
did they saved themselves nearly 500
million dollars now Paramount having to
do the same Prodigy which I'd love to
talk about in a minute and why I think
it got canceled has been canceled but
it's not just been canceled it's been
removed from the server with a bunch of
other stuff now why did this happen for
the same reason it happened at Disney
Paramount to having to cut costs it's
not just about saving money on future
Productions even though they're going to
have to do that as well
it's actually about cutting the costs of
actually putting all this stuff on
servers that serve a worldwide audience
now I did a video about a month ago
talking to you about how Star Trek is
possibly in a little bit of trouble now
I have a couple of sources that work at
Paramount that talk to me about this
they actually are not the biggest fan of
Alex kurtzman's project now I don't
personally have a problem with most of
new track I don't like bits I would
prefer they spent a little less time on
special effects and a little more time
on actually getting the stories right
but other than that I actually quite
enjoy strange new worlds I love low
decks I loved Prodigy I am gutted it got
canceled
um and I am in two minds about Discovery
I like it sometimes I don't like others
I'm in two minds about future plans I
don't want to see Star Trek 90210 it
doesn't interest me in the slightest but
the TV movie with Michelle yo section 31
does excite me and I am told that we
will be getting a Stargate Legacy type
project that that story will be
continuing but I am here to talk about a
few realities a few realities that a lot
of trekkies don't like the reality is
the Paramount plus is
potentially a failing experiment it just
does not have enough subscribers to
sustain it Paramount has mounting debts
and really if it wasn't for the success
of Maverick last year the situation
would be even worse and at Paramount
there are Executives that one do not
like the contract that they currently
have with secret hideout and for two
don't think the secret hideout has
actually done the best job with Star
Trek that they could have done and
perhaps they should be looking to remove
Star Trek from secret hideout and maybe
bring it within CBS Studios or find a
new partner now that gets complicated
because secret hideout do actually have
rights they have a contract Etc and they
own certain elements of the Star Trek
franchise or at least they own certain
elements of what they've produced
through the Star Trek franchise so my
source tells me look it's not as easy as
just sacking Alex gertzman that's just
not how this works
but there is mechanisms in place to
maybe sideways steps some of the Star
Trek stuff and get it into other
people's hands and in the video that I
mentioned that I did a couple of weeks
ago I said really that Strange New World
success was vitally important that
actually a lot of these vultures were
already circling around Alex kurtzman
and it was only really the Michelle yeoh
deal which was a surprise and really the
success of Star Trek Picard season 3
that has given him a little bit of
breathing space that breathing space
though will rapidly diminish and
disappear if strange new worlds isn't a
big success
so is it well we've got to the third
episode of the new season I've done a
couple of videos already saying that
look I'm not the biggest fan of these
episodes I thought the first episode
wasn't very good after admit it just
wasn't very good I enjoyed the second
episode a lot more even though I
questioned the logic of the end and I've
actually had a couple of debates with a
couple of trekkies about it and they've
not been able to convince me I'm open to
being wrong but they've not been able to
convince me that I am I think that whole
Asylum thing was poorly conceived and
I'm pretty sure they could have thought
of a better way around that if they'd
spent a little less time on the special
effects I love a good space battle
beautiful show
but it's really let down by some details
in the story but anyway is strange new
worlds doing well well I went on to Flix
Patrol to have a look at the top 10 TV
shows for Paramount Plus
worldwide
today June 28th Star Trek strange new
world is in 10th
is behind shows like South Park maybe
another surprise in Yellowstone not a
surprise it is behind the rookie not a
surprise it's also behind SpongeBob
SquarePants from pinental and reruns of
Sabrina the Teenage Witch
you really should be doing better than
that but
that's worldwide
when you look at the USA you get a
different picture strange new worlds is
number one it's number one today it was
number one last week it was number one
the week before only the Tulsa King star
Sylvester Stallone is even getting close
to it
and actually if you look at the numbers
for the United Kingdom they're similar
it's not quite as popular I believe it's
in like second or third place over here
in the UK but still top of the charts
for Paramount so for them a success it
really doesn't matter how many people
are watching it it only matters that
it's the number one show for Paramount
right now
the problem is that around the rest of
the world
it's at nine and ten and that drags down
the worldwide audience now I don't know
why this isn't popular in France
or even Australian which is English
speaking but it isn't it's not being
watched it's barely getting into the top
ten
that's a problem for a show that costs
as much as this show costs to make
now that is a big problem for Star Trek
moving forwards cost
as I've already discussed Paramount
desperately needs to save money they
have already said 2023 is going to be
the peak of spending and from now on
they will be spending a lot less
investors are actually demanding it
and they're going to look at a show that
costs anything from 7 to 11 million
dollars an episode to produce
I'm thinking we need to spend a lot less
a series of strange new worlds costs
upwards in the region of a hundred
million dollars and if the show isn't
even getting into the top 10 in 25 of
the countries you show it in that's a
problem
so look Prodigy I think had some
conceptual problems and that's why it
has been canceled I was not particularly
surprised I'm surprised that they've
removed it from the service so rapidly
especially considering they've already
actually produced the second season I
thought they would at least show them
get the views and then maybe move it
unless there's a deal to actually sell
it to somebody else which again I'm
going to come back to in a minute but I
actually genuinely think Prodigy was
conceived poorly it was a TV show for
kids aimed directly at kids put onto a
kid's Network initially it was then
split in two which was a very bad idea
and there was ages between the first
parts and the second parts so people had
virtually forgotten what happened in the
first part before then we finally got
the second
but also it had loads and loads of
references from a TV show that's 20
years old now I actually mentioned this
to a tracking and they disagreed me they
said no it didn't it stood up on its own
because those relationships Etc were
explained and I would actually say to
them watch it again but put yourself
into a child's mind constantly think
about what a child that hasn't watched a
voyager understand that reference
because I am telling you that's how I
thought about it when I watched it and
it was constant there was constant
references that I'm just thinking
anybody hasn't much Voyage who doesn't
get that
and also more than that the relationship
between Janeway and chicote now yeah
okay it is mentioned that she wants to
save jakote and she has a strong feeling
for him but it's not really explained
why it's only if you've watched a
voyager that you understand the
relationship between them I mean from a
very basic point of view you have to
understand that Voyager was lost in you
know another quadrant of the Galaxy and
took Asia to get home if you don't know
that
large sections of the Prodigy episodes
don't really make sense
but
as an adult watching Prodigy as a fan of
actual Star Trek Voyager I loved it
and to be honest
it's loads cheaper to produce now I know
a lot of people don't like animated they
just like it's for kids I don't like it
anything I actually get comments on the
Channel all the time any new project
that's going to be an animated movie
something some people just go okay
animate and look I I don't I get it I
understand but as a Trekkie I was
watching prodigy
final space battle
was awesome
and I mean we saw the Enterprise E we
saw all these other vessels it was a
very very cool battle scene and in a
live-action
um series that's a scene would have cost
millions of dollars to produce but as an
animated series and it was done to a
high standard it's much much less a
fraction of that cost we got to see
loads of aliens loads of backgrounds and
loads of scenarios Etc that just
wouldn't be possible in a big live
action Series without spending the 7 to
11 million dollars an episode we talked
about earlier it's just not practical so
I want live action but I actually don't
mind an animated series that runs along
it like Prodigy because they get to tell
the story in a slightly different way
and I just think that adds loads of
richness to the Star Trek franchise it
really is a shame that we lost Prodigy
but is that the beginning of the end for
Star Trek so if strange new worlds fails
if it just doesn't get those numbers
could we lose Star Trek for another
generation like we did after Star Trek
Enterprise
at the end of the day Paramount is in
trouble
but there is an out for paramed it's
something they've done before
sound Star Trek to other streaming
services partner up with Netflix partner
up with Amazon like they did for the
first two seasons of um Discovery like
they did for the two seasons of Picard
like I suspect they've done with the
second season of Prodigy it will not
surprise me at all if there's already a
deal in place for that to appear aren't
say Amazon
because streaming services actually love
animated projects they are really cheap
and they get really good views so
somewhere like Netflix would give their
left arm for a series like Prodigy and
the other thing is even as an adult we
love binging this stuff I watch the
entire He-Man Series in an afternoon and
even that wasn't very good I still loved
it
so if Prodigy appeared on Netflix next
week I've watched the hell out of it who
knows whoever that provider then is say
Netflix maybe just maybe they would
actually commission another series
because there is a lot of love for this
Prodigy series and deservedly so there's
a petition out there that within a
couple of days has already got well over
25 000 names on it
that is huge for something like this
so I'm really hoping that maybe this
isn't the end for The Prodigy series and
I'm really hoping it's not the end for
Star Trek but Paramount are going to
have to get very creative about how
they're going to pay for it in the
future and maybe they are going to have
to go back to their previous business
strategy and share Star Trek with other
streaming services
because I'd love to know what you think
did you enjoy prodigy or was it just a
stupid kid show you never bothered
watching if you didn't bother watching
it and you're Trekkie
give it a go please because it was
brilliant
also I'd love to know what you think
about the streaming Wars now that
they're over and it feels like everyone
lost
are we gonna have to see some merges are
we gonna have to see Paramount Plus on
Netflix say or something similar
I'd love to know exactly what you think
so please get to the comments if you are
new to the Channel please like subscribe
hit the Bell notification you'll never
miss any of our new videos you know what
to do hit all those buttons and go over
to patreon.com forward slash Sidetrack
where you get to see most of our new
videos first and for a small
contribution each month that really
supports the channel and you get a free
gift you get to see them without the
adverts
as always though please stay safe and
I'll see you next time
foreign